[Music]
what we're live welcome to another
exciting episode of the walking dead i'm
your host gorda gruesome but only for
today because I've been fired our new
host couldn't start till next week so
this is my last show today's episode is
brought to you by calling arts of
productions put in a crap and craft
services I heard that uh-huh well I
heard your wife left you for baboon at
the zoo we are the walk
Oh
Oh
on today's episode of The Walking Dead
will be taking a request from a user
named Brice makes films he writes hey
Gordon I'm turning 21 next year have any
recipes for drinks I should try well
Bryce lucky for you I've got just the
thing first start by preheating the over
and over the outfit to 500 degrees hold
on Gordon what do you need the oven for
get a security thing Oh what oh and
here's what you'll need schnapps Irish
cream and Gretel di it's grenadine
grenadine and since I really needed this
job arsenic what back to back haha and
the first thing for you to do is open
the bottle of schnapps
[Music]
oh and if you run out you can just get
more and put it on the company card give
me that no you're a dick Dave but
exactly one ounce into the glass I
[Music]
forgot oh this is important on a second
oh and then I said you could forget
about your grandma's orange juice
because I'm not coming back and then I
slammed the door courting can't you see
that I'm on the phone just finish the
show already I'll call you back where
was I oh yeah irish cream
you put in onesies nothing you [ __ ] we
could have a top of the world together
here we put you had to go off with that
query lesurfr boy with the timeless
bagel what does it even mean I'll show
her I'll show all of you just wait why
are all the clouds purple we are inside
courting so finally the last ingredient
is one have Z spoon of Gerald I
[Music]
you're telling me willing to pour three
ingredients into a cup o is actually
look pretty good Gordon I think you've
had enough right why don't you just take
us out come to another episode of The
Walking Dead this week the other one
thanks for walking the watching dead
remember subscribe free room kitchen
well get him out of here oh I'm sorry
for Gordon's behavior but join us next
week as we introduce a new host uh I
hope to see you then there's no way we
can present this to our viewers it's
completely unprofessional look we have
to upload an episode every month that's
what the fans expect the first three
they were pretty disastrous but there
was something there this it's complete
anarchy you can't upload it you are
obligated to deliver an episode every
month doesn't really matter what's in it
nobody will notice probably did you even
see that abomination I don't know if
you'll excuse me I have some business to
attend to